what up theo what up tom it's your boy
daniel have your fits in um arizona i
gotta ask i know tom's new lifestyle
probably doesn't allow much fast food
but
mcdonald's
or burger king
not donald trump
my daughter says not donald's
gang gang gang gang bro
it's not even a debate
yeah mcdonald's that's mcdonald's yeah
what is burger king doing i mean come on
they've they've really dropped the ball
man do you remember they used to have
the little thing where they had the uh
pictures of like the handicapped kid
wheels or whatever their characters used
to be like 20 years ago or 30 years ago
they used to have a picture of a
handicapped kid yeah the mcdonald's kids
club and like all of their group like oh
mcdo you saw you said burger king oh no
this was a burger king kids club burger
was like here's radar you know and it
was like a tall like black guy with like
uh his name was glasses or something you
know and he was like here's uh wheels
and it was like a handicapped ginger no
i don't remember that at all you know
that used to be their whole thing it was
like this kind of mcdonald's kids color
there they are
and uh
yeah they had the handicapped ginger
right there yeah like santino in the
chair oh definitely very much
those are the good old days though
do you like burger king
you know what i i didn't mind their
dessert menu like in the probably early
2000s but i don't like anything they
have now i never liked the whopper yeah
no i'm gonna eat it
i mean dude like you know look if if you
have no options you're gonna you know i
mean like there's certain road trips
where you're like we gotta eat
eventually at some point and you pull
off and there's like one place and a lot
of times you just settle for whatever's
[ __ ] there right but i mean if you
have options yeah come on take
mcdonald's over that [ __ ] every time
you're burking at that chicken they're
saying suck that
the fried one the breaded one it was
good right it was so good yeah the
traditional chicken sandwich i think it
wasn't
yeah some of the other choices they've
made have just been extremely downhill
the king that was like scaring people in
their bedrooms and stuff was their
advertising weird
because even now the handicapped ginger
the scary king even now though you
imagine like imagine what burger king's
marketing budget is it's got to be just
astronomy billion dollars i bet crazy
money and you can't find a [ __ ]
advertising company to get your [ __ ]
straight like look at what some of these
companies do with advertising it's
amazing yeah you know like they should
[ __ ] hire like comedians somebody
like really like a good comic to get
involved with them but this [ __ ] hey
look at this a drooling
this guy it's a gut it's like a it's saw
five it looks like a goddamn horror look
it's terrifying man
and the burger yeah it's known that the
burger they paint the stripes on it it's
not even at least just say hey
they paint the stripes on that
yeah dude they don't [ __ ] cook that
what grill do you see at a [ __ ]
burger king dude it's two sisters in the
back [ __ ] about the fists
what's your opinion on if you're taking
like the national big name
burger people five guys what a burger uh
sake shack
in and out where do you where do you
land
how do you wendy's
wendy's yeah over everybody you too
i go in and out i think it's like a
different yeah i don't know and you're
you're both wendy's yeah i like in and
out because i love they have a lot of
latino employees and that's what and
that's my favorite yeah because latina's
always there it's just such a
hard-working group i really like that
vibe you know yeah yeah i think they're
gonna in and out
the training is obviously superior to
every other place by far the way they
treat you talk to you even have people
like you know sometimes you go to a fast
food place you're like you're a [ __ ]
mess yeah your whole life's a mess you
just know it and then in and out they're
like you go like what are you doing
they're like i'm getting my engineering
degree yeah and they're like like they
just look like they have their [ __ ]
together yeah yeah i agree they're do
yeah they're learning we've gotta be
reading and doing the fryer he'll
actually be reading
yeah see on the tv shows exactly but
they're that's
they're they're primo man yeah i never
thought even to bring wendy's into the
conversation really wendy's is next
level for me wendy's is very unique
really
well yeah look at burning and yeah the
whopper always looks like it [ __ ] got
in a domestic dispute
yeah
it does it does
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one